from actors standing up for writers to
getting canceled by a superhero filming
The Adams Family was a wild ride for
everyone involved
when it comes to Gomez atoms there are
two names who immediately come to mind
John Aston and Raul Julia both actors
helped to shape the Beloved character
with a Snappy dress style a delightful
mustache and total Devotion to his wife
and family considering the Adams family
members never had first names before the
television series aired the classic show
all but shaped who they were and how
they would behave going forward however
it could have been very different had
Aston been cast for the original role he
was earmarked for speaking to the AV
club the actor explained how he wasn't
required to audition because of his
status at the time it also helped that
he was familiar with the Adams Family
he'd collected Charles Adams cartoons
when he was in college so he was
particularly excited to be a part of the
show the role he was initially pitched
was that of lurch which Aston admitted
seemed daunting this plan changed though
after producer and Show creator David
Levy contacted Aston with another
suggestion Aston told the AV club he
said the show is really Father Knows
Best with different people and I want
you to be the father and then we'll cast
the rest of it so we discussed it
further and I realized that I could make
up a character because there were really
only a couple of Clues from Charles
Adams cartoons
naming a child Wednesday isn't the most
outrageous parental act ever committed
however the case of Wednesday Adams is
intriguing because it now seems like a
fitting name for her personality and
appearance
day still one has to wonder who came up
with the idea to name her after a
weekday in the first place according to
a letter sent to the New Yorker Joan
Blake claimed credit for the name after
a chance encounter with Charles Adams at
a mutual friend's party in the 60s Blake
wrote in the letter Charles Adams made
me laugh and told me that the Adams
Family was being made into a television
show and that he had no name for the
little girl I said Wednesday Wednesday's
child is full of Woe and Wednesday
became her name according to the book
The Adams Family in evolution Blake's
story does check out as Adams mentioned
it was a friend who suggested Wednesday
after reciting the line from the nursery
rhyme Monday's Child
there are many creators who despise
adaptations of their work but according
to The Adams Family producer David Levy
Charles Adams was nothing but supportive
of the classic television series writing
for the Los Angeles Times Levy stated
the following in 1964 at Christmas time
Charles Adams wrote to me that the TV
series was a stylish great show in 1986
two years before he died he wrote to me
again stating that he still viewed the
series with satisfaction however Levy
doesn't believe Adams would have looked
at the live action films quite as fondly
believing they missed the mark of what
The Adams Family was really about of
course this is simply Levy's thoughts on
the matter as Adams passed away three
years before the 1991 film was released
perhaps if Adams had still been alive he
might have had some input for the final
product
Cousin It is arguably one of the most
beloved characters of The Addams Family
however it didn't make his debut in
Charles Adams cartoons but rather the
classic television series as per the Los
Angeles Times actor felixilla who played
cousin it said a producer dreamed it up
in some nightmare cilla's sole purpose
was to walk around in costume for the
scenes that required him while the lines
for the character would be dubbed in
later in the post-production process
there was one problem cilla's costume
was made from real hair which made it
extremely heavy and dangerous since
everyone on set liked to smoke fearful
that he might be set on fire one day The
Producers changed his costume to a much
safer option which featured synthetic
fireproof hair the Adam's house has
become a critical part of any version of
the spooky family in various
interpretations it has taken the shape
of a mysterious Haunted Mansion and the
classic television series employed a
similar approach as well while most of
the action took place inside the home
which was shot in a studio set the
outside of the house was featured in the
show's intro publicity photos and the
first episode it would have been
possible to utilize a model house for
the footage but there was an actual
Adam's house in Los Angeles California
well for a short while at least
according to 21 Chester place a website
that covers the history of this famous
property the production company used the
house for stock footage since the
company didn't own the property it
employed an effect Studio to add the
necessary details to the footage and
photographs unfortunately the fabled
Adams House no longer exists as it was
demolished in 1967. Lurch might look all
doom and gloom as if someone stole his
secret stash of chocolate cookies but
there's a lot more to the Adam's
staggering Butler than meets the eye the
role of lurch is a part that features a
lot of nuance and subtlety something not
many actors can pull off Ted Cassidy not
only delivered a fantastic performance
as Lurch in The Addams Family TV series
but he also became the measuring stick
for the character that all other actors
will be judged by surprisingly Lurch was
the first television role where viewers
got to experience both Cassidy's voice
and face as he had only done voice over
work before standing at six foot nine
Cassidy had a successful semi-pro
basketball career especially in the
college leagues however the
entertainment bug bit when he secured a
gig as a radio DJ then at the age of 30
he decided to give acting a try
fortunately due to his towering frame
and distinctive voice he was deemed the
perfect person to bring Lurch to life
you rang sir you're fired taking one
look at the patriarch in Charles Adams
cartoons and John astin's Gomez it's
clear there are differences in their
appearances as Aston explains the AV
club The Producers allowed him the space
to shape the character for the show and
to Tinker with the source material
however in a separate interview with the
television Academy Foundation he
explained how he received pushback from
the network as it wanted Aston to shave
the sides of his head to look more like
the character from the cartoons
fortunately for Aston producer and Show
creator David Levy backed his ideas and
ultimately allowed the actor to choose
the path for Gomez Aston told the AV
club I wanted to look more attractive
and I thought that would work better and
turns out one of the strongest elements
of the show is the Gomez Morticia
relationship Aston believed this tweak
to his character's appearance further
fueled the natural Chemistry Between
Gomez and Morticia on the show
considering how they are still seen as a
Guiding Light for couples around the
world it appears as if aston's decision
was right on the money
while John astins Gomez Carolyn Jones
Morticia and Jackie Coogan's bester may
have stolen all the Limelight when The
Adams Family television series was
released the children also inspired a
generation Lisa loring's Wednesday
became a future goth icon while Ken
weatherwax's Pugsley became the living
embodiment of the macombre nature of the
show for Weather Wax though the role
became more of an albatross than a
Kickstarter for a successful career
speaking to Bill O'Reilly Weatherwax
revealed how he struggled to find acting
gigs after The Adams Family since most
producers only saw him as Pugsley yes I
went out and interviewed for several
roles but I was Typecast to Pugsley the
role also took a toll on his personal
life as he experienced bullying from his
classmates Weatherwax told O'Reilly
frankly I didn't deal with it very well
I was kicked out of about six or seven
schools and ended up in the service at
the age of 17. most five-year-old
children are still busy learning to read
and write not even giving a second
thought to what they want to be when
they grow up Lisa Loring admitted to the
Sydney Morning Herald the same was
applicable to her as she had to learn
how to memorize their lines before she
could even read for her role as
Wednesday Adams on The Addams Family
television series it certainly made no
difference though since the show changed
her life and made her one of the most
well-known child actors in the industry
luring revealed that she didn't have a
comprehensive filmography when she
auditioned for Wednesday yet she still
secured the role over another young
actor auditioning for the part it seemed
surprising that Lauren came out on top
since there's often a natural reluctance
from Productions to cast very young
children Loring claimed the reason for
her Casting success was because of her
uncanny resemblance to Carolyn Jones who
portrayed her on-screen mother Morticia
despite The Adams Family television
series finding its audience and becoming
a runaway success it only lasted for two
years on the air in an interview with
the television Academy Foundation John
Aston revealed how surprised he was to
hear that the show had been canceled
though he knew the then president of the
network had a slightly different sense
of humor which may have impacted the
abrupt decision however Aston expressed
how another Show's debut may have also
played a pivotal role in the
cancellation Aston told the television
Academy Foundation Batman had come on
opposite the monsters and a lot of the
programming people thought about atoms
and monsters as the same kind of show
Batman came on with a big rush it was a
storm and tough to go up against I think
there was some thinking that the Adams
Family would go away you shallow brain
simpletons where's your imagination your
ambition Aston appeared in Batman
portraying The Riddler in season two of
the show while Ted Cassidy's Lurch also
made a guest appearance in an episode
there's Sage advice that says never mess
with a winning formula but in the world
of TV Executives they love nothing more
than to tweak and change things even
when the show is a Smash Hit and
everything works well it turns out The
Addams Family television series wasn't
immune to this phenomenon either as John
Aston revealed to the AV club the actor
gushed about working with producer and
series Creator David Levy and head
writer Matt Perrin explaining how there
was a natural artistic Synergy between
all parties and how it developed into a
friendly working relationship however
the production company decided it wanted
to replace Levy and parents so Aston and
Carolyn Jones intervened to get their
old crew back Aston told the AV club at
one point they replaced David and Nat
and they hired somebody else to direct
and write but Carolyn and I got together
and said you know this isn't what we
signed up for and we went to filmways
the producers and said you've got to get
David and Nat back and they did
well reboots are fairly common in both
film and television The Adams Family
television series unprecedented success
scared off potential suitors from trying
to redo it the franchise lived on
through various animated shows and
live-action films but there was a fear
of Reviving the series until 1998. the
new Adam spam featured a brand new cast
with John Aston later making guest
appearances as Grand Papa Adams the show
won a few Leo Awards in 2000 and
introduced a new generation to this
kooky family but it didn't have the same
lasting impact or cultural influence as
the original series ironically there's
also a misconception that the new Adams
Family was short-lived in comparison to
the original that's inaccurate though
since the classic television series ran
for 64 episodes from 1964 to 1966 while
the new Adams Family aired 65 episodes
from 1998 to 1999. of course the
original series returned for a reunion
TV film and the cast provided their
voices for the characters in other
projects however the new Adams Family
still holds the distinct honor of
lasting for one more episode than its
predecessor
[Music]